So hello here. This is a cold open to our upcoming episode of Smartless. The cold open is Jason, the cold open is... Where we do a little bit of banter. Have we prepared anything? We've prepared nothing. Can we just get a suggestion from the audience? What is it?
大家好，这是我们即将播出的 Smartless 节目的一段简短开场白。开场白是由杰森来主持的，开场白就是……我们在这闲聊一会儿。我们准备了什么吗？我们什么也没准备。我们可以从观众那里听取一个建议吗？是什么呢？
That'd be great. Bananas! Bananas. Bananas is the prompt yeah right it makes me think of what it makes me think of is breakfast sure welcome to smart list terrible terrible cold open Hey, Sean. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Anything you'd like to say to the listening world?
那就太好了。香蕉！香蕉。香蕉就是提示，对，这让我想到了……让我想到的是早餐。当然，欢迎收听 Smartless，一个糟糕透顶的开场白。嘿，肖恩。对，对，对。你有什么想对听众朋友们说的吗？
I did go recently with me and Scotty and two other friends to an escape room and it was, um, have you ever been? Have you ever been? Was it inside your house? Well, you know why I haven't been? Because you know who went to an escape room this weekend? Nash, for his seventh birthday. Yeah.
我最近和我和斯科特还有另外两个朋友去了一趟密室逃脱，那感觉，嗯，你们去过吗？你们去过吗？它是开在你家里的吗？好吧，你知道我为什么没去过吗？因为你知道这个周末谁去过密室逃脱吗？纳什，为了庆祝他七岁生日。对。
Couldn't get in, there were too many seventh graders in there. You know what else Nash is into? Lightsabers. That's right. Star Wars. But let me tell you, but I like the problem solving of escape rooms.
没能进去，里面有太多七年级学生了。你们知道纳什还喜欢什么吗？光剑。没错。星球大战。不过，我跟你说，但我挺喜欢密室逃脱那种解谜的感觉。
Do you have a mirror close by? I need you to look in the mirror right now. I need you to fucking have a conversation with yourself right now and say, fuck it, dude, I blew it. Have you ever done it? You blow it! Have you ever done it? I don't think I have.
你附近有镜子吗？我现在需要你照照镜子。我需要你现在他妈的好好跟自己对话，然后说，操，老兄，我搞砸了。你做过这种事吗？你搞砸了！你做过这种事吗？我觉得我没有。
Yes, I have. After all that, yes. What with your kids though, right? Yeah, I did it with with the kids but I will say it's really fun and it's hard Here's part of the other thing that people don't understand when we Just I haven't done one in years and it was great Is that well you were in that real right? We didn't were you in some guy he built a thing in his basement and he tried to put you in there You're in there for like 18 months or some shit.
不，我有。经历了这一切之后，是的。不过是跟你的孩子们一起，对吧？对，我是和孩子们一起去的，但我得说这真的很有趣，而且很难。这就是人们不理解的另一件事，当我们……我好几年没玩过了，感觉棒极了。就是……你当时就在那个真实的里头，对吧？我们没有……你是不是在某个家伙的地下室里，他建了个东西，然后他试图把你关在里头？你在里面待了大约 18 个月还是什么的。
The dog was over here. You were like in the... But that was consensual. Hey, where could I get our hair? What are you guys saying? Wasn't there some thing that he wanted you to put lotion in the basket or something? What happened with that?
狗在那边。你就像在……但那是自愿的。嘿，我在哪儿能弄到我们的头发？你们在说什么？难道没有什么事情是他想让你把润肤露放进篮子里什么的吗？那到底是怎么回事？
Yes, I'm telling you it was consensual. I forget the detail. I remember you telling me once. Anyway, that's an escape room. But I will say that we like to give each other shit because I was thinking about, I give you telling me once. Anyway, that's an escape room. But I will say that we like to give each other shit because I was thinking about, I give you shit, I rip on it, like no, it's for fucking kids, and blah, blah, blah, and of course I've done it myself.
对，我跟你说那是自愿的。我忘了细节了。我记得你以前跟我说过。不管怎样，这就是密室逃脱。但我得说，我们喜欢互相开玩笑，因为我在想，我跟你说过。不管怎样，这就是密室逃脱。但我得说，我们喜欢互相开玩笑，因为我在想，我开你玩笑，我吐槽它，比如不，那是给小屁孩玩的，云云，当然我自己也玩过。
And so then people sometimes will go like, you guys are just too mean, or whatever, I'm like, yeah, we're fucking around, man, we're just having a laugh. You know what I really enjoyed with the kids is laser tag. Have you guys done those ones? Yes, I have. I won with a bunch of 12 year olds, I won.
所以有时候人们会说，你们俩也太刻薄了，诸如此类的。我就说，行啦，我们就是瞎胡闹，老兄，我们只是开个玩笑逗乐而已。你知道我跟孩子们在一起时真正喜欢的是什么吗？是激光枪战。你们玩过那个吗？玩过，我赢了。跟一群十二岁的小孩一起，我赢了。
Yeah, no, no, here comes Sean again with another adult play date. I did it with Bella Bejaria for her birthday. You did it with Bella, Netflix's greatest Bella Bejaria. Yeah, yeah, we did it for her birthday one year. Come on. That was my call. There was a long time ago.
对，不，不，肖恩又带着另一个成年人的约会来了。我是跟贝拉·巴贾里亚一起去的，为了给她过生日。你是跟贝拉一起去的，Netflix 最伟大的贝拉·巴贾里亚。对，对，有一年我们是为她生日去的。拜托。那是我的提议。那是很久以前的事了。
Remember when it was really fun, remember when everybody was like super hipster and it was like, hey, we're gonna go do kickball, adult kickball league, then we're gonna go do laser tag, and then we all drive old BMX bikes. Or I've got an ironic bicycle. Do you have an ironic bicycle? Like, you know what I mean?
还记得以前真的很好玩的时候吗，还记得当时所有人都超级嬉皮士，然后就会说，嘿，我们要去踢球，成人踢球联赛，然后我们要去玩激光枪战，接着我们全都骑着旧的 BMX 自行车。或者我有一辆标新立异的自行车。你有一辆标新立异的自行车吗？就像，你知道我的意思吗？
Wait, did you do paintball? I did, my oldest brother Dennis for his wedding. I was the best man. So this is decades ago. You know what? I did paintball training for a movie once. Paintball? Yeah, when we did Kingdom,
等等，你们玩过真人 CS 吗？玩过，为了我大哥丹尼斯的婚礼。我是伴郎。所以这是几十年前的事了。你知道吗？我曾经为了一部电影做过真人 CS 训练。真人 CS？对，当我们拍《王国》的时候，
we had to go out and do paintball fights. And it was really, really scary getting hunted by someone. By guns. I was talking to the kids who went paintballing last week, I was just talking to them on the way to school today about paintball. It's fun, right? I've never done it, I've always wanted to do it.
我们必须出去进行真人 CS 对战。被人追杀感觉真的、真的挺吓人的。用枪。我上学路上还在跟上周去玩真人 CS 的孩子们聊真人 CS 的事呢。很好玩，对吧？我从来没玩过，我一直很想玩。
Oh, it's really painful. I killed somebody with a real gun. Oh, welcome to Dr. Gettlis. Let's get to the guest, let's get to the guest. I do want to get to the guest. No, JK. Let's get to the guest, she's been waged. I want to get to the guest too, but hang on,
哦，那真的很痛。我用真枪杀过人。哦，欢迎来到格特利斯医生。我们聊聊嘉宾吧，聊聊嘉宾。我确实想聊聊嘉宾。不，开玩笑的。我们聊聊嘉宾吧，她已经等很久了。我也想聊聊嘉宾，但是等等，
I just want to say, here's the thing, I was just going to go on a couple things about, do we have a segment yet called just Stuff I Hate, or Should We, or? We absolutely should. Pretty kind of unofficially covered every week with you. Yeah, thank you, thank you. In the body of the show.
我只是想说，事情是这样的，我本来要讲几件事，关于我们有没有一个叫做“我讨厌的东西”的环节，还是说我们应该有，或者？我们绝对应该有。基本上你每周都会非官方地提到。对，谢谢，谢谢。在节目的主体部分。
It's a new expression that I'm adding to Storyteller which is Everywhere You Go Now. And I think it started in the golf world, I think, but it's everywhere and it drives me fucking crazy. Welcome in. Oh, this is drives me fucking crazy, welcome in. Welcome in. Phrases that we'd like to never hear again. Have you heard people say welcome in?
这是我给 Storyteller（讲故事的人）加的一个新表达，叫做“你现在走到哪里”。我想它是从高尔夫界开始的，我想是的，但它无处不在，快把我他妈的逼疯了。欢迎光临。哦，这就是“快把我他妈的逼疯了”，欢迎光临。欢迎光临。我们再也不想听到的短语。你们听过别人说“欢迎光临”吗？
I haven't had that one. You go, welcome in. Why are we saying in? Just say welcome. If you feel the need to say, just say welcome. Wait, two that I have that I don't like is because I watch a lot of football now, as you know. Have a day. Have a day.
我没听过这个。你会说，欢迎光临。我们为什么要在后面加个“进”字？直接说“欢迎”就行了。如果你觉得非得说，那就只说“欢迎”好了。等等，我有两个我不喜欢的，因为如你所知，我现在看很多美式橄榄球。度过美好的一天。度过美好的一天。
Have a day is, well I said this the other day when all the announcers always go, as we got some play action, they like just saying play action. Just say they have the ball or whatever they're doing. I brought that up to our friend that we did the show with, JB, I brought that up to Peyton Manning last week. Yeah. Yeah.
“度过美好的一天”是……好吧，我前几天当所有解说员总是说，当我们有一些战术配合时，他们就像只是在说战术配合。直接说他们拿球或者他们在做什么就行了。我把这事提给了我们一起做节目的朋友 JB，我上周把这事提给了佩顿·曼宁。对。对。
I brought up, I said that you hated, that they overuse play action. Play action, yeah. Because they make it, and then when you're on a flight, they go, Stuart, is it cross check? Cross check and something? Cross check. Cross check. Yeah, cross check.
我提到了，我说你讨厌他们过度使用战术配合。战术配合，对。因为他们把它弄成……然后当你坐飞机时，他们会说，斯图尔特，这是交叉检查吗？交叉检查和别的什么？交叉检查。交叉检查。对，交叉检查。
Is the door secure or not? Yeah. How about, how about, you know what I'm glad they're not saying much more, much anymore is touch base. Yeah, let me touch base. Yeah, by no way. I'm gonna circle back, I'm gonna circle back. Circle back or in the theater world they say,
门锁好了没有？对。还有，还有，你知道我很高兴他们不再怎么说的词是什么吗？那就是“对接”（touch base）。对，让我跟你对接一下。绝对没有这回事。我要“回电跟进”（circle back），我要“回电跟进”。回电跟进，或者在戏剧界他们会说，
oh, it's in a great space. Oh, we found a great space to do that piece. If we're gonna go deep, if we're gonna go deep these days, a welcome in, again, I guess it feels kind of folksy, but the other thing that has exploded in the last couple years. Well, for the five years before it was, people all of a sudden discovered the word narrative
哦，那是一个很棒的空间。哦，我们找到了一个很棒的空间来排练那部作品。如果我们打算深入探讨，如果我们这些天要深入探讨的话，“欢迎光临”，再次说明，我觉得这听起来有点土气，但另一件在过去几年里爆炸式增长的事情是……好吧，在这之前的五年里，人们突然发现了“叙事”这个词，
who didn't know it and they overused it. That's true, that's true. But the other one is, to your point, everybody go, to his point. Oh, but I say it all the time on this show. I know you say it a lot, you sound like a moron. And it's been you, you do. And it is so overused. No, but I mean because you want. The one that's very overused now is right.
那些原本不懂它的人却过度使用了它。确实如此，确实如此。但另一个是，就像你说的，每个人都说，“正如他所说”。哦，不过我在节目里经常这么说。我知道你经常说，你听起来像个白痴。而且一直都是你，你就是这样。而且这词被严重滥用。不，我是说因为你想……现在被严重滥用的是“对吧”。
Very educated people will be telling a story and we're going along, right, and blah, blah, blah, right. And it's like, no, you don't need to keep pulling me along with right, I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you.
很有教养的人在讲故事时，我们顺着说，对吧，然后巴拉巴拉，对吧。这就好比，不，你不需要一直用“对吧”把我拉着走，我跟你是一伙的。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。
I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you.
我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。
I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm with you. very educated people will be telling a story and we're going along, right, and blah, blah, blah, right. It's like, no, you don't need to keep pulling me along with right. I'm with you, I'm nodding. If we don't need to. Pulling me along. I think that that's been around for a while though.
我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。很有教养的人在讲故事时，我们顺着说，对吧，然后巴拉巴拉，对吧。这就好比，不，你不需要一直用“对吧”把我拉着走。我跟你在一起，我在点头。如果我们不需要的话……把我拉着走。不过我觉得这个说法已经存在一段时间了。
I feel like. It's used much, much, much more often now. My God, you guys, we have to get to the guests. We're going to get to you in a second. Sit tight. Okay, so I know that I complain a lot and all of that shit drives me crazy, and I'm sorry, so thank you for bringing,
我觉得是这样的。现在它的使用频率高得太多太多了。天哪，伙计们，我们得采访嘉宾了。我们一会儿就采访你。别急。好吧，所以我知道我抱怨了很多，所有这些破事都让我抓狂，我很抱歉，所以谢谢你提出来的……
however, you know what doesn't drive me crazy? You know what I'm really excited about? Sean, you know what I'm going to say. Uh oh. It's the new Smartless Media. Clueless. Clueless. Don't leave me hanging when I say.
不过，你知道什么没有让我抓狂吗？你知道我真正兴奋的是什么吗？肖恩，你知道我要说什么。噢不。那是全新的 Smartless Media。Clueless（一无所知）。Clueless。当我说话的时候别把我晾在一边。
It's a new podcast, folks. I set you up. I know, but I wanted you to give it to you. Could it be called a podlet? Could it be called a podlet? Oh, it's a podlet. I keep being hanging when I say, I set you up. I know, but I wanted you to give it to you. Could it be called a podlet? Oh, it's a podlet. Oh, it is a podlet. It's only like 10 minutes long.
各位，这是一个新的播客。我给你铺垫好了。我知道，但我想让你自己说出来。它能被称为 podlet 吗？它能被称为 podlet 吗？哦，它是个 podlet。当我说话时别把我晾在一边，我给你铺垫好了。我知道，但我想让你自己说出来。它能被称为 podlet 吗？哦，它是个 podlet。哦，它确实是个 podlet。它只有大概 10 分钟长。
Yes, that's great. It's a little podlet, Jason. You are, I would smooch you right now. So this is a new podlet called Smartless Presents Clueless. Just a million little kisses. I'm gonna smooch you. So yeah, so that's great. It's a podlet.
太棒了。这是一个小 podlet，杰森。你，我现在就想吻你。所以这是一个名为《Smartless Presents: Clueless》的新 podlet。只有一百万个小吻。我要亲吻你。所以，是的，这太棒了。它是一个 podlet。
It is called SmartList Presents Clueless and it's a bite-sized twice-weekly puzzle pod. Because there's a bunch of puzzles, like if you like Wordle and stuff like that and the New York Times crosswords, you'll love this. They're 10 to 12 minute podlets. It's really fun. The host is Elliot Kalin.
它叫做《Smartless Presents: Clueless》，这是一个一口大小的、每周更新两次的益智播客。因为里面有很多谜题，如果你喜欢 Wordle 之类的东西和《纽约时报》的填字游戏，你会爱上这个的。它们是 10 到 12 分钟的 podlet。真的很有趣。主持人是埃利奥特·卡林。
He's the former head writer of The Daily Show with Jon Stewart. So you're the permanent contestant or the permanent host? Permanent contestant. You're permanent contestant and then other contestants come in, they work in conjunction with you. And you guys did the first show.
他曾担任《乔恩·斯图尔特每日秀》的首席编剧。所以你是常驻选手还是常驻主持人？常驻选手。你是常驻选手，然后其他选手会加入进来，他们会和你一起合作。你们做了第一期节目。
We did it. I was kind of clueless about what it was about until I got on it. Very, very nice. So every Monday and Thursday, don't miss the fun. You can subscribe to Clueless wherever you get your podcasts. Anyway, let's get on to the guest. Smartless.
我们做了。在加入之前，我对它是关于什么的几乎一无所知。非常，非常棒。所以每周一和周四，千万不要错过乐趣。你可以在你获取播客的任何地方订阅 Clueless。不管怎样，我们来聊聊嘉宾吧。
Yeah. My guest today, this is very exciting. This is a long time coming for me, huge fan. My guest today is a box office powerhouse. I refer to her as the triple A actress. I'll explain in a little bit. In the early 2000s, you might remember her as a ballet dancer trying to get picked for the American Ballet Academy in New York
是的。我今天的嘉宾，这太令人兴奋了。对我来说这可以说是期待已久，我是她的超级粉丝。我今天的嘉宾是一位票房巨星。我称她为 AAA 级女演员。我一会儿再解释。在 2000 年代初期，你可能还记得她是一个试图入选纽约美国芭蕾舞学院的芭蕾舞演员，
City or from taking a cross-country road trip with Britney Spears. Huh? Anything? However her recent notable characters are mostly blue and green in complexion and I can't wait for the new movie to come out I can't wait to talk about it and although she herself is hip and cool every sci-fi nerd like me knows who she is. It's the magnetic, the most incredible, Zoe Saldana. Zoe Saldana. Hello there. Hello there. Woo!
或者是因为和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯进行了一场跨国公路旅行。哈？有什么想说的吗？不过她最近标志性的角色大多是蓝色和绿色的皮肤，我等不及新电影上映了，我等不及要聊聊它了。尽管她本人时髦又酷，但像我这样的每一个科幻迷都知道她是谁。她就是极具吸引力、最不可思议的——佐伊·索尔达娜。佐伊·索尔达娜。你好啊。你好啊。哇！
Good morning. I'm so excited, this is so exciting for me. First of all, it was exciting to listen to you guys talk. I was mesmerized, we were just like the normal conversation. We're always nervous that we're like, the person is sitting there thinking like, these guys are ding-dong. Hey, I'm so excited to see Amelia Perez.
早上好。我太兴奋了，这对我和说太激动人心了。首先，听你们聊天就很让人兴奋。我当时听入迷了，我们就像平常聊天一样。我们总是担心自己听起来像个傻瓜。嘿，我好兴奋能看到《艾米莉亚·佩雷斯》。
I have it. Yeah, I'm singing tomorrow. Well, should we watch it tonight? Do you have it? Yes. Yeah, let's watch it tonight. Oh my God, please watch it tonight. Okay, and then we're gonna,
我有。对，我明天唱。好吧，我们今晚看吗？你有吗？有。好吧，我们今晚看吧。天哪，请今晚看吧。好的，然后我们……
then where should we email our notes? Cuz you guys aren't locked yet, right? We'll get them to you just you guys can do pickups, right? I'll give you I'll give you my email and then you can you can I'll forward it to Jack actually I'll give you Jack O'Diard's email He doesn't speak English. Is that true? Was all the communication via an interpreter during the film?
然后我们该把我们的笔记发到哪里？因为你们还没剪辑完，对吧？我们会把它交给你，你们可以去补拍，对吧？我把我的邮箱给你，然后你可以……其实我会把它转给杰克，我把杰克·奥迪亚的邮箱给你。他不会说英语。真的吗？电影拍摄期间所有的交流都是通过翻译进行的吗？
Yes. Yes, we had many interpreters and there were many languages spoken. It was Spanish and English and French and some Italian. And are you bilingual? Do you speak all of those? I'm kind of. I was raised bilingual, but I'm kind of trilingual now,
是的。是的，我们有很多翻译，也说了许多不同的语言。有西班牙语、英语、法语还有一些意大利语。你是双语者吗？你所有这些都会说吗？我会一点。我是在双语环境中长大的，但我现在差不多算三语了，
because my husband's Italian. Oh wow. And I picked it up after so many years. Wow. Also, always figuring out whether or not he was hustling me. It's not like Italians are hustlers. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
因为我丈夫是意大利人。哦，哇。而且过了这么多年我也学会了。哇。另外，还得一直琢磨他到底有没有在忽悠我。意大利人可不是什么骗子。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，
it speaks flow, what is that? No, but it was great, but Jack is known for working outside of his language. This is not the first foreign film that he's done. He did a film called Deep Bound, which was with these Indian actors, and then he did a film years before called A Prophet, and that had some Arabic as well.
它说得很流利，那是什么？不，但这很棒，杰克以在母语之外工作而闻名。这并不是他拍的第一部外国电影。他拍过一部叫《深渊》的电影，演员是印度的，然后他在此之前几年拍过一部叫《预言者》的电影，里面也有一些阿拉伯语。
He's not defied by language. He likes to kind of connect with human beings and challenge himself. And when it comes to whether or not they speak the same tongue, he just likes to find ways to communicate with people and connect with people. I love that. You know, don't you think that would be really difficult
他没有被语言所局限。他喜欢与人类建立联系并挑战自我。至于他们说的到底是不是同一种语言，他只是喜欢寻找与人交流和连接的方法。我喜欢这样。你知道吗，你不觉得如果不是在你的母语环境中，去评估一个人的表演会非常困难吗？
to gauge somebody's performance if it's not in your native tongue? Right, because I mean think about all the ways you can vary a reading of a line and the nuance of it. And if you don't know the language that there, it's hard to read intonation, I don't know. Maybe, but here's the thing. I think as somebody that speaks different languages,
对，因为你想想看，你解读一句台词的方式有多少种，还有其中的细微差别。如果你不懂那里的语言，就很难读懂语调，我不知道。也许吧，但情况是这样的。我觉得作为一个会说不同语言的人，
but also understanding that English is a very distinct language, I feel like that exists mainly in English, rather than the romantic languages. It's more of a feeling than the words. I was gonna say. It's hard to explain. of, it's more of a feeling than the words. Like, you know, like. I was going to say. Right.
但同时也理解英语是一种非常独特的语言，我觉得这种情况主要存在于英语中，而不是罗曼语族。与其说是词汇，不如说是一种感觉。我正要说呢。很难解释。与其说是词汇，不如说是一种感觉。就像，你知道，就像。我正要说呢。
It's hard to explain. Jason, I don't know if you've ever heard of this, but love is a universal language. Wait, what? What's love? Tell me what it is. I know, it's side dish. Yeah.
很难解释。杰森，我不知道你有没有听说过这个，爱是通用的语言。等等，什么？什么是爱？告诉我那是什么。我知道，那是配菜。
No, no. When did you guys finish that? We shot it, we shot it summer of 2023. Okay. Oh wow. From April to like July, right? We shot it summer of 2023. Okay. Oh wow. From April to like July, right? And we wrapped right before the strike.
不，不。你们是什么时候拍完那部戏的？我们拍的，我们是 2023 年夏天拍的。好的。哦，哇。从 4 月到 7 月左右，对吧？我们是 2023 年夏天拍的。好的。哦，哇。从 4 月到 7 月左右，对吧？我们在罢工前夕杀青了。
Like a couple of days before the strike. Are you so happy with it? By the way, it's in my notes to get to at the end of this interview, but we're talking about it now. You, including three of your co-stars, won the award in Cannes for best performances, right? It's pretty, pretty outstanding.
就像罢工前几天。你对它超级满意吗？顺便说一句，我在采访结束时才准备聊这个，但我们现在就在谈论它。你，包括你的三位联合主演，在戛纳电影节上获得了最佳表演奖，对吧？这真是相当、相当出色。
I can't wait to see this. It looks, because on paper, I was reading the description, it was like singing and dancing and this and that and other, but other like storylines that I want to give away, but like, it sounds incredible. And there's like danger and like a robbery or something too, right, or like, I mean, it's got everything. You know, it dabbles in so many different genres
我迫不及待想看这部电影了。它看起来……因为在纸面上，我读剧情简介的时候，里面有唱歌、跳舞、这个那个以及其他各种……还有其他一些我不想剧透的剧情线，但听起来太不可思议了。而且里面还有危险，比如抢劫什么的，对吧，或者说，我是说，它应有尽有。你知道，它涉足了如此多的不同类型，
and it doesn't stay in one place. And I feel like that, that just feels fresh. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We all signed up to work with Jacques Odiar. I've been a fan of his work since I was a teenager. And he was one of those top three directors in my bucket list that I felt would never happen. Right.
而且不局限于某一个地方。我觉得，这感觉很新鲜。对，对，对。我们所有人都是为了跟雅克·奥迪亚合作才签约的。我从十几岁起就是他作品的粉丝。他是我的心愿清单上的前三名导演之一，我曾觉得这永远不会发生。对。
When this opportunity came, it's like a niche of a niche movie. It's in Spanish, it's a musical. It centers around four women. The main character goes through a major transition, trying to find herself. And everything about this felt dangerous and super risky. So it was totally aligned with what I wanna do,
当这个机会到来时，这就像是一部小众中的小众电影。它是西班牙语的，是一部音乐剧。它围绕四个女人展开。主角经历了一次重大转变，试图寻找自我。关于这一切，感觉既危险又超级冒险。所以这完全符合我想做的事情，
with who I feel like I am, you know, and I wanna reconnect with that part of me as an artist. I didn't think that it was going to be seen by many, many people. I just thought I was gonna scratch something out of my bucket list and feel so happy that I collaborated with an amazing filmmaker. Gunn was a surprise for us.
符合我觉得自己是谁的认知，你知道，我想作为艺术家重新连接我身上那一部分。我当时并不认为会有很多人看到它。我只是觉得我可以勾掉心愿清单上的一个愿望，并为自己能与一位优秀的电影人合作感到无比高兴。戛纳对我们来说是个惊喜。
Isn't that amazing? Yeah, I was out there. Was it just like all like the pomp and circumstance of that festival and it was just like glamorous and fantastic all the way through it? It must have been amazing. Yeah, well I mean, and he is, you know, he's a fan favorite.
这不是很奇妙吗？对，我当时在那儿。是不是就像那个电影节所有的盛况和礼仪一样，整个过程既迷人又美妙？那一定棒极了。对，我的意思是，而且他，你知道的，他是粉丝的最爱。
They're very proud of their own, you know. So Cannes was a wonderful festival to premiere Emilia. But I think it's the movie. I think this movie feels really important and it's audacious and it's provocative and it's a bit campy and melodramatic. And those are things that I think audiences are wanting to have a little bit more of. Sometimes films can be so linear and that makes them a little cold, sterile, you know? I agree. Stories sometimes can get really sterile when you try to do everything right. What if you throw everything away and you sort of go off script and you fall and you
他们对自己的同胞感到非常自豪。所以戛纳是首映《艾米莉亚》的绝佳电影节。但我认为关键在于电影本身。我觉得这部电影意义重大，它很大胆、很具有挑衅性，还有点怪异和情节剧色彩。我认为这些正是观众们想要看到更多一点的东西。有时候电影可能会过于线性，这会让它们显得有点冷冰冰的、死气沉沉的，你知道吗？我同意。当你试图把每件事都做得完美时，故事有时会变得非常死气沉沉。如果你把一切都抛开，有点像不按剧本走，去跌倒，
collaborate with your artists as opposed to sort of kind of being super stuck with a vision and this is the vision and this is the vision. Jacques sort of like is very much a traditional director, but he's also a person that is yearning to connect with people through cinema. Otherwise he would be locked up in his room like just reading, He's an avid reader, he's an intellectual mind, and he's a bit shy in social gatherings. So cinema
去与你的艺术家合作，而不是死死守住一种愿景，这就是愿景，这就是愿景。雅克在很大程度上是一位传统导演，但他也是一个渴望通过电影与人连接的人。否则他就会把自己锁在房间里不停地阅读。他是一个狂热的读者，有着知识分子的头脑，在社交场合还有点害羞。所以电影
and storytelling is the way that he kind of connects with the world. And the way that he allows his artists, and also every department, to add to the story, it just felt like an experiment. And that within itself became the experience of Amelia Barres for us. Wow, that's so cool. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Zoe, you talk about bucket lists.
和讲故事是他与世界建立连接的方式。他允许他的艺术家以及各个部门为故事添砖加瓦，这感觉就像是一场实验。而这本身就成为了我们拍摄《艾米莉亚·佩雷斯》的经历。哇，太酷了。对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。佐伊，你谈到了心愿清单。
Where did that bucket list start for you? Where and when? Where were you when you decided that you wanted to be a performer? It's funny. I'm a Gemini. I live a very absent-minded life. I don't make conscious decisions.
你的那个心愿清单是从哪里开始的？在哪里，什么时候？你是在哪里、什么时候决定自己想成为一名表演者的？这很有趣。我是双子座。我过着一种十分心不在焉的生活。我不会做出深思熟虑的决定。
I just go with the flow. I knew what I didn't want to do. But where was that? Where were you? Where'd you grow up? New York. I was born in New York. I was born in Jersey, but I don't like to say that.
我只是随波逐流。我知道自己不想做什么。但那是在哪里？你在哪里？你在哪里长大的？纽约。我出生在纽约。我出生在泽西岛，但我不太喜欢这么说。
Close enough. But because we're New Yorkers since 1961. I'm a daughter of immigrants, and my grandma arrived there in 1961, and we're like native New Yorkers. So in New Yorkers since 1961. I'm a daughter of immigrants and my grandma arrived there in 1961 and we're like Native New Yorkers. So in New York, partially, and then at the age of 10, we moved to the Caribbean. So we did sort of like the reverse migration. We went back to where my family's from
差不多吧。但因为我们自 1961 年起就是纽约人了。我是移民的女儿，我奶奶在 1961 年来到那里，我们就像是地道的纽约人。所以自 1961 年起就是纽约人了。我是移民的女儿，我奶奶在 1961 年来到那里，我们就像是地道的纽约人。所以我们在纽约待了一段时间，然后在 10 岁时搬到了加勒比海。所以我们有点像是进行了反向移民。我们回到了我家人所在的故乡，
and I did, you know, my formative years, like from 10 to 17, 10 to 18, I lived there. And then we returned back to New York. I think that the beginning of my bucket list happened unconsciously, I must have been like six or seven, and James Cameron was probably the first name there. Oh wow. Along with like Steven Spielberg.
我度过了我的成长岁月，大概从 10 岁到 17、18 岁，我一直住在那里。然后我们又回到了纽约。我想我的心愿清单的起点是无意识的，我当时大概六七岁吧，詹姆斯·卡梅隆大概是上面出现的第一个名字。哦，哇。还有史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格。
There were films that were very memorable to me when I was growing up because of the characters. Like Sarah Connor was this character that just spoke to me. She's just an Ellen Ripley. Ellen Ripley spoke to me. She was just this amazing woman that found ways to survive against these extraterrestrials that were looking to use her body as a host.
我在成长过程中，有一些电影因为其中的角色给我留下了极其深刻的印象。比如莎拉·康纳这个角色就深深打动了我。她就像是另一个艾伦·雷普利。艾伦·雷普利打动了我。她是一个如此了不起的女性，在面对那些企图把她的身体当作宿主的太空外星人时，找到了生存的方法。
And what a gamble for James at the time or for anybody to stick a woman in the lead with that much power and strength. And for Steven Spielberg James at the time, or for anybody to stick a woman in the lead with that much power and strength. And for Steven Spielberg, the ET man, the shark man, to then direct the color purple, and Whoopi Goldberg, this character became so, when your little life is just bigger and brighter and more impactful.
对于当时的詹姆斯或者任何人来说，把一个具有如此强大力量和坚韧意志的女性放在主角位置，是一场多么大的赌博啊。而对于史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格，那个执导过《外星人》、拍过鲨鱼电影的人，转而去执导《紫色》，让乌比·戈德堡这个角色变得如此……当你的小生活变得更大、更明亮、更具影响力时。
So I think that unconsciously I was tapping into art in the way that films were just taking me with them, you know, and making, building a reality for me that was healing, that was medicinal, you know, when I needed it. Like I was very much, I'm one of three girls, but I'm a solitary person. Maybe there's a little bit of,
所以我想我是在无意识地汲取艺术的力量，电影陪伴着我，你知道的，为我构建了一个具有治愈作用、充满药效的现实，你知道的，在我需要的时候。我其实……我有三个女孩，但我是一个独来独往的人。也许有一点，
I'm on the spectrum of some sort, I guess, but in the 80s nobody really talked about that. But my sisters are able to sustain relationships with friends and function. And I was sort of like this loner that was protected by my sisters because sometimes I would annoy people because of whatever, what was, you know.
我有点在某种光谱上吧，我想，但在 80 年代没有人真正谈论这个。但我的姐姐们能够维持与朋友的关系并且正常社交。而我有点像那种被姐姐们保护着的独行侠，因为有时我可能会因为某些原因惹恼别人，你知道的。
So art and storytelling became my go-to place, you know, reading books and science fiction and watching films and being these characters, you know, became really real to me. And it wasn't until I was a teenager and I kept clashing, my dad died when I was nine. I'm telling you everything, I really real to me. And it wasn't until I was a teenager and I kept clashing. My dad died when I was nine. I'm telling you everything.
所以艺术和讲故事成了我经常去的地方，你知道的，阅读书籍、看科幻小说、看电影、成为这些角色，你知道的，对我和说变得非常真实。直到我十几岁的时候，我一直在冲突，我父亲在我九岁时去世了。我把什么都告诉你了，对我来说真的非常真实。直到我十几岁的时候，我一直在冲突。我父亲在我九岁时去世了。我什么都告诉你了，
I feel like Chunk from The Goonies, you know? Everything, everything, okay, I'll try. That's great. But no, you know, my dad died and my sisters and I, we were eight, nine, and ten. And that was like a big, you know, life-changing sort of event in our lives. And art became this healing sort of, you know,
我觉得自己就像《七宝奇谋》里的楚克，你知道吗？什么都说，什么都说，好吧，我尽量。太棒了。不过不，你知道的，我父亲去世了，我和姐姐们当时分别八岁、九岁和十岁。这对我们来说是一个重大的人生转折点。艺术成了这种具治愈作用的……你知道的，
assistant to my mom and to us that really helped us. So they did, my sisters became, they got, she painted, and Cicely and I, my younger sister, and I, we started dancing ballet. And that helped me sort of, it helped me just cope with shit, you know? Because life is hard when you're little, socializing, starting over in a new environment,
对我妈妈和我们的一种实质帮助，真的帮了我们很多。所以，我的姐姐们，她画画，西西莉和我，还有我妹妹，我们开始跳芭蕾舞。这帮我应对那些破事，你知道吗？因为当你年纪还小的时候，生活是很艰难的，要社交，要在新的环境中重新开始，
different language, different people, different culture. That's always like a very big thing for kids. And- I heard you say in an interview once that you, I don't know if you were joking or not, that you were kind of an arsonist at some point. Yes. Wait, wait, wait, what?
不同的语言，不同的人，不同的文化。对孩子们来说这总是一件大事。而且……我听你在一次采访中说，我不知道你是不是在开玩笑，你曾经是个纵火犯。是的。等等，等等，什么？
Is that true? Well, I have three boys and one of my boy just lives on his own. He's like this lone little wolf and I guess I feel kindred to him. Yes, I would do weird shit that my mom, I think that my mom became an insomniac because I would wake up in the middle of the night.
真的吗？我有三个男孩，其中一个男孩完全独来独往。他就像是一只孤独的小狼，我想我对他的这种特质感同身受。是的，我会做一些奇怪的事，我妈妈……我觉得我妈妈都快得失眠症了，因为我会在半夜醒来。
I don't remember these things, by the way. Now she's just jokingly mentioning them. And I'm just like, well, mom, that's some serious stuff. She goes, I know, I know. One time you just, I don't know if you were sleepwalking, you just turned on the hot water and you got in the tub and you burned yourself. Oh, you just turned on the hot water and you got in the tub and you burned yourself.
顺便说一句，这些事我都记不清了。现在她只是开玩笑似地提起它们。而我就会觉得，好吧，妈妈，这可真够严重的。她说，我知道，我知道。有一次你只是……我不知道你是不是在梦游，你只是打开了热水，然后坐进浴缸里把自己烫伤了。哦，你只是打开了热水，然后坐进浴缸里把自己烫伤了。
Oh, jeez. It was two o'clock in the morning and she was just like, is my kid crazy? Am I not really addressing this? Is my kid off? I would turn on toasters or turn on the stove and boil an egg, but I wouldn't put water in the pot. I would just throw the eggs inside the pot.
哦，天哪。当时是凌晨两点，她心里想的肯定是：我的孩子疯了吗？我是不是没有真正处理好这个问题？我的孩子是不是有点不正常？我会打开烤面包机，或者打开炉子煮鸡蛋，但却不在锅里放水。我直接把鸡蛋扔进锅里。
I would like, I guess she said, and at one point you liked the way the eggs sounded when they broke inside the pot. And I was like, oh, how interesting. So I have a little one that does that. Well, it was like sleep, it was probably sleepwalking, no? Or just curious, just a naturally curious child that probably needed a lot of verbal communication in order for me
我想……她说，有一次你甚至喜欢听鸡蛋在锅里破裂时发出的声音。然后我想，哦，真有意思。所以我也管着一个会做这种事的小家伙。好吧，这就像是梦游，可能是在梦游吧？或者只是出于好奇，一个天生好奇的孩子，可能需要大量口头沟通，才能让我
to understand my sensations. I was a sensory seeker. I was always seeking things that catered to my ears and taste and my feelings. It's just sensory seeking, I guess. I want to know, I think we all want to know how you started performing. Was it a school play or was it inspiration from a show or a movie or something?
理解自己的感受。我是一个寻求感官刺激的人。我总是寻找能满足我的听觉、味觉和触觉的东西。我想这只是在寻求感官刺激吧。我想知道，我想我们都想知道你是怎么开始表演的。是一场学校戏剧，还是来自某部剧、某部电影的灵感之类的？
What was the thing that got you, what was that first thing that got you going performing? I transitioned, I danced ballet for like 10 years and I realized that I couldn't break, I couldn't shatter my glass ceiling, I didn't have the feet. And that became a very just painful confession to tell yourself, you know? But then it was like transition. I love storytelling and I was able to tell stories with my body. So I was in this little theater company in the city and I was playing Mrs. Potiphar from Joseph and the Amazing Technical Dream called Musical.
是什么促使你开始表演的，第一件让你行动起来的事是什么？我过渡了，我跳了大约 10 年的芭蕾舞，然后我意识到我无法打破自己头顶的玻璃天花板，我没有那双脚。对自己承认这一点是一个非常痛苦的坦白，你知道吗？但随后这就成了一种转变。我热爱讲故事，我能够用我的身体讲故事。所以我当时在城里的一家小剧场公司，我在音乐剧《约瑟夫的神奇彩衣》中扮演波提法太太。
And there was a manager there. I was about to sing all the songs, but okay. Joseph, he will, yeah, exactly. It's such a great musical. And there was a manager there and she signed me and I first started going to, like, I would book commercials. So my first gigs were doing, I did a Burger King commercial.
那里有一个经纪人……我差点要把所有的歌都唱出来了，好吧。约瑟夫，他会……是的， exatamente（没错）。这真的是一部很棒的音乐剧。那里有一个经纪人，她签了我，我最初开始去……我会去拍广告。所以我的第一份工作是拍广告，我拍了一个汉堡王的广告。
Two for two or something. Just the two of us. And I remember, I got my SAG card from that commercial. Yeah, but that's big though. I mean that's a big deal. It was, it was. And that's when I knew, I'm like, one, I didn't want to do commercials.
两块二之类的。只有我们两个。我记得我靠那个广告拿到了演员工会卡。对，但那可是件大事。我是说那是件大事。是的，确实是。那就是我明白的时候，我心想，第一，我不想拍广告。
I knew then. And I was like, I just want to act. I want to play characters. I want to tell stories. I want to be other people. Zoe, the amount of big, huge budget spectacle films that you've done is... Assounding.
我当时就知道了。我就想演戏。我想扮演角色。我想讲故事。我想成为其他人。佐伊，你拍过的大预算奇观电影的数量实在是……太惊人了。
Yeah, I mean, I don't know if anyone's done more than you. Well, Jason, I referred to you in the intro as the triple A actress, which means the top three movies of all time you're starring in, which is Avatar, Avatar the Way of Water, and Avengers. You're probably the only actor in all three. That's crazy. Today, today.
对，我的意思是，我不知道有没有谁比你拍得更多。好吧，杰森，我在开场白里提到你是 AAA 级女演员，这意味着史上票房前三的电影你都主演了，也就是《阿凡达》、《阿凡达：水之道》和《复仇者联盟》。这三部里你大概是唯一的演员。这太疯狂了。今天，今天。
I know that these records will always be. But that's astonishing. But then there's Guardians, and then there's. Yeah, it's pretty incredible. But then like Star Trek. Even like the smaller films are cool. Like Out of the Furnace is one of my favorite movies of all time. Oh my God, it was such a good story.
我知道这些纪录将永远……但这是令人震惊的。但还有《银河护卫队》，还有……是的，这相当不可思议。但还有《星际迷航》。甚至连一些小成本电影也很酷。比如《逃出熔炉》就是我这辈子最喜欢的电影之一。哦，天哪，那真是一个好故事。
I just think it's just stunningly good. And Center Stage, I love Center Stage by the way. Do you have a... I mean, I bet you'll say you like doing both, which I'm sure everybody would, but when you're on one of those big, huge movie sets, you might not do much more than like a half a page over the course of a week, right? Where you're doing one of those big huge movie sets, you might not do much more than a half a page over the course of a week, right?
我只是觉得它好得惊人。还有《中央舞台》，顺便说一句我很喜欢《中央舞台》。你有没有……我的意思是，我敢打赌你会说你两样都喜欢，我相信所有人都会这么说，但当你身处那些宏大的电影片场时，在一周的时间里，你拍的内容可能不会超过半页剧本，对吧？而在拍摄那些小成本电影时，你有时一天就要拍五、六页。你有什么偏好吗？
Where you're doing the smaller films, you're doing five, six pages a day sometimes. And do you have a preference? I mean, I like everything. I think that I'm going to answer the way you were expecting. But Avatar was really special in the sense that the way that we shoot it I wish I wish people can understand that the technology does not substitute the performances it only supplements the performances you know
我的意思是，我都喜欢。我想我会给出你们意料之中的回答。但《阿凡达》非常特别，因为我们拍摄它的方式……我希望人们能够明白，技术并不能替代表演，它只能是对表演的补充，你知道吗，
and you got things sticking out of your head and you're so real I mean you're like we go through months of training because it is, it's basically Jim Pints, you know, those pixelated, you know, things over what we do. So he's, it's not that we sit in a studio and we record like an animation. This is like all the work that you do is the work that you see, you, and that form of acting is incredibly,
而且你头上插着各种东西，你是如此真实，我的意思是，我们经历了好几个月的训练，因为这基本上就是吉姆·平茨（译者注：此处可能口误指 Jim Paints 或动作捕捉技术），那些在我们表演之上的像素化……你知道的东西。所以，这不是说我们坐在录音室里像做动画那样配音。这就像是你所做的所有工作就是你在银幕上看到的工作，而那种表演形式简直令人难以置信，
just exciting. So what you guys do is you'll stand and you will perform the scene, and they will shoot it with a camera just like normal. And then, and this is a question, and then afterwards they then take that real footage, which usually is the movie that we all see, but they take that footage and then they create
就是让人兴奋。所以你们做的是，你们会站着把场景演出来，他们会像正常拍摄那样用摄像机把它拍下来。然后——这是一个问题——随后他们会拿走这段真实的画面，通常就是我们所有人看到的电影，但他们拿走这段画面，然后据此创建
a digital version of your bodies and basically create effectively digitally animated characters from it? Yes. Okay. But it's not an animator that is guessing, or estimating how you're moving. No, no, it is your performance
你们身体的数字版本，并基本上有效地从中创造出数码动画角色？是的。好的。但这不是动画师在盲目猜测或估算你的动作？不，不，这就是你的表演，
because they have these reference cameras, but Jim has also created this gimbal of a camera that is, it's in Pandora. So when you're moving, there are all these big screens. Let me know if I lose you. When we're shooting, we're shooting in a set that we call the volume. And the reason why it's the volume is because
因为他们有这些参考摄像机，而且吉姆还创造了这个像万向节一样的摄像机，它在潘多拉星球里。所以当你移动时，周围有所有这些大屏幕。如果我讲得太抽象了随时告诉我。当我们拍摄时，我们在一个我们称之为“演播总体积空间（the volume）”的布景里拍摄。之所以叫这个名字，是因为
all these cameras that are attached in the ceiling of our set are pointing all through this sort of square, this space that's called the volume. So once you're in and you have all these dots and you have to, you ROM yourself in, so they enter you called the volume. So once you're in and you have all these dots and you have to, you ROM yourself in, so they enter you into the system. So it's all these motion capture points on your body, yeah? And you're wearing this helmet that has these cameras here
所有固定在我们布景天花板上的摄像机都指向这个被称为 volume 的方形空间。一旦你进去了，身上贴满了所有这些点，你需要将自己输入（ROM yourself in）系统，所以他们把你输入进这个系统里。所以你身上有所有这些动作捕捉点，对吧？而且你戴着这个头盔，上面有这些摄像机，
that are also then registering every single muscle on your face. So they sync all of that information and you then once you enter the volume you're in Pandora on real time. So you and I can be talking standing in the volume and if we stare at the screens that he has all through the volume facing us we're seeing ourselves as avatars in Pandora where we're standing. So what he does is he documents everything
它们同样会记录你脸上的每一块肌肉。所以他们会同步所有这些信息，一旦你进入那个 volume，你就会实时身处潘多拉星球。所以你和我可以站在 volume 里交谈，如果我们盯着他在 volume 里正对我们放置的那些屏幕，我们就会看到自己作为阿凡达站在潘多拉星球上我们正站着的地方。所以他所做的就是记录下这一切，
and his technicians, he works with people from Weta in New Zealand and he has people from all over the world, but they're mainly here in Los Angeles and in New Zealand. They're just basically painting over what we're doing because it's already in the system. Does that make sense? Yeah, and is the overall goal of that as opposed to like, let's say in Star Wars,
他的技术人员——他与来自新西兰维塔工作室的人合作，他还有来自世界各地的人，但他们主要在洛杉矶和新西兰。他们基本上就是在我们所做的事情上面进行绘制，因为这些已经录入系统了。这说得通吗？对，那这么做的总体目标是——相比之下，比如说在《星球大战》中，
you have like a real person mixed into a later down the line created digital environment. So you have a real person in a created digital environment. Like a green screen. Right, in Avatar, is the goal, the reason that he's taking you and putting you into a digital form so that your digital form is in the same medium
你有一个真人混合到一个后来创建的数字环境中。所以你有一个真人在创建的数字环境中。就像绿幕一样。对，在《阿凡达》中，他的目标、他把你放进数字形态的原因，是不是为了让你的数字形态和数字创建的环境处于同一媒介中，
as the digitally created environment as well so that there's no difference between the, say a human body in a digital form, in a digital environment in Star Wars versus with this, it's a digital form inside a digital form, in a digital environment in Star Wars versus with this, it's a digital form inside a digital environment. So everything is the same in the medium. Is that the reasoning?
这样一来，比如在《星球大战》中数字环境里的数字形态人类身体，与这个相比就没有区别了，这里是数字环境里数字形态内的数字形态？所以一切都在相同的媒介中。这就是原因吗？
I think so, you kind of blew my mind there. I was like, oh my God, he's really taking it there. Yes, yes, that might be the, if what you're saying is what I'm understanding, then yes. Yes, will you call me later and explain it to me? What do you think? It's funny, I was just trying to put everything in the same thing, right?
我想是的，你刚才真的把我给震撼到了。我当时想，天哪，他真的说到做到。对，对，可能，如果你说的是我理解的那个意思，那确实。对，你等会儿能打电话给我解释一下吗？你觉得呢？真搞笑，我刚才只是想把所有事情都归纳到一件事情上，对吧？
Yes. Well, Jim has always said that putting a human being with an animation always felt unreal. Two different things. It looks different. It's like who framed Roger Rabbit? You remember how Zemeckis, it's Zemeckis, right? That's George Lucas.
对。嗯，吉姆一直说，让真人与动画结合总是感觉很不真实。两码事。看起来不一样。就像《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》？你还记得泽米吉斯，是泽米吉斯拍的吧？那是乔治·卢卡斯。
Is it Zemeckis or Lucas that did Roger Rabbit? Robert Zemeckis. Robert Zemeckis, thank you. So these filmmakers have always been ahead of their time and they've always tried to sort of invent the technology that is able then to allow them to capture their vision. Jim is that same. I call them kind of scientists.
拍《兔子罗杰》的是泽米吉斯还是卢卡斯？罗伯特·泽米吉斯。罗伯特·泽米吉斯，谢谢。所以这些电影人总是走在时代的前面，他们总是试图发明能够让他们捕捉到自己愿景的技术。吉姆也是这样的人。我把他们叫做某种科学家。
Because they're inventing things that will later on down the line just evolve the way that we make films and the way that we view films, right? So for Jim, the challenge was to make a human being and an alien, an animated alien, look as if they were in the same medium, yes. So that was his goal. And he achieved it with Avatar. and an alien, an animated alien, look as if they were in the same medium, yes.
因为他们发明的东西在未来会推动我们拍电影和看电影的方式不断演变，对吧？所以对吉姆来说，挑战在于让真人与外星人、一个动画外星人看起来好像身处同一个媒介中，对。所以这就是他的目标。而他通过《阿凡达》做到了这一点。和一个外星人、一个动画外星人，看起来好像身处同一个媒介中，对。
So that was his goal, and he achieved it with Avatar. And you're doing number four and number five right now? Yes, we finished three, so now they're just, they have a year now to basically render all of the information that we shot, everything that we shot. So how long did it take to shoot your scenes, the actor scenes?
所以这就是他的目标，他通过《阿凡达》做到了这一点。你现在正在拍第四部和第五部吗？对，我们拍完了第三部，所以现在他们，基本上有一年的时间来渲染我们拍摄的所有信息，我们拍摄的一切。那么，拍你们的戏份，也就是演员的戏份，花了多长时间？
Well, I only play a Navi, I'm not an avatar. So, ours is the shortest sort of shoot, and it takes anywhere between five to seven months to shoot. And then after that, then they go to New Zealand, and they spend a year there sometimes, shooting live action, and they'll do the green screen and then they'll assemble the whole thing in the same medium. And that takes a lot of time.
嗯，我只扮演纳美（Navi）人，我不是阿凡达。所以，我们的拍摄期可以说是最短的，拍摄时间大概在五到七个月之间。在那之后，他们会去新西兰，有时会在那里待上一整年，拍摄真人动作，然后他们会做绿幕，再把整部作品在同一个媒介中整合起来。这需要很长时间。
It's, you know. I mean, the first time I saw it, I have to say, we're getting to your other movies other than just Avatar, but your portrayal of Neteary is like, I was so real. I had to be, like when I went in, I was like, what's this going to be about? I kind of like had a thing and I was like, it was so real. And that had to be, like when I went in, I was like, what's this going to be about? I kind of like had a thing and I was like,
你知道的。我是说，我第一次看的时候，我必须得说，我们待会儿会聊到除了《阿凡达》之外你的其他电影，但你对奈蒂莉（Neteyari）的塑造实在是太真实了。我当时不得不，就像我去看的时候，我在想，这到底讲的是什么？我当时心里有点底，然后我想，这也太真实了吧。我当时不得不，就像我去看的时候，我在想，这到底讲的是什么？我当时心里有点底，然后我想，
you know, years and years ago when the first one came out, and I was like, wow, that's like, that's Zoe being like, being this person. It was wild to see, wild to see. And incredible. It's beautiful when actors collaborate with their filmmakers. And that was the very first time that I had an experience It's beautiful when actors collaborate with their filmmakers.
你知道的，多年前第一部上映的时候，我在想，哇，那就是佐伊在扮演这个角色，成为这个人。看到这一幕真是太震撼了，太震撼了。而且令人难以置信。当演员与电影人合作时，那种感觉真的很美妙。那是我第一次有这种经历，当演员与电影人合作时，那种感觉真的很美妙。
And that was the very first time that I had an experience where I was cast very early on in the process of putting the Navi together. You know, in terms of how do they walk, how do they speak? How do they speak English with a Navi accent? All these things. And I was like, I was 27. And working with my childhood dream of a director, the Sarah Connor creator, and he was allowing me to collaborate with bringing the Navi to life.
那是我第一次有这种经历，在把纳美族构建起来的整个过程中，我很早就被选中了。你知道，关于他们怎么走路，怎么说话？他们怎么带着纳美口音说英语？所有这些事情。当时我27岁。而且能和童年梦想中的导演、莎拉·康纳的创造者合作，他允许我参与将纳美族人带入现实的过程。
So I was working with Cirque du Soleil performers and dialect people and stunt people, like how do they fight, how do they move, you know that tail, it's kind of like an extra limb. It felt like going to school or being in a laboratory and conceiving a brand new organ, like life. It was great. Because I didn't expect to feel is what I meant to say.
所以我当时和太阳马戏团的表演者、方言专家还有特技演员一起工作，比如他们怎么打斗、怎么移动，你知道那条尾巴，它有点像多出来的一肢。感觉就像去上学或者在实验室里孕育一个崭新的器官，就像生命一样。感觉太棒了。因为我没想到自己会产生那种感受，我是这个意思。
I didn't expect to feel as much as I felt. I didn't expect to get emotional and you did it. So it's just a feat. By the way, sidebar, combined, your sci-fi films have earned over $4 billion at the box office. Just over $4 billion. Yeah, isn't that amazing?
我没想到自己会有这么深刻的感受。我没想到会被触动到情绪，而你做到了。所以这真是一个了不起的成就。顺便说一句，题外话，综合起来看，你的科幻电影在全球票房已经超过了40亿美元。刚刚超过40亿美元。对，是不是很惊人？
Hope you have a great deal. Yeah, you're the only actor in history to have starred in four films that have grossed over $2 billion individually. Two billion? Wait, what did you just say? What did you just say? She's the only actor in history to have starred in four films that have grossed over two billion dollars individually. Can you wrap your head around that? What did you just say? She's the only actor in history to have starred
希望你赚了一大笔。对，你是历史上唯一一位主演过四部全球个人票房均超过20亿美元电影的演员。二十亿？等等，你刚才说什么？你刚才说什么？她是历史上唯一一位主演过
in four films that have grossed over two billion dollars individually. Wow! Jesus. Yeah. I like that you say starred. That's really nice. For half of those projects, I was a part of them,
四部全球个人票房均超过20亿美元电影的演员。哇！天哪。对。我喜欢你用的是“主演”这个词。这真的很棒。其中有一半的项目，我是其中的一部分，
but I do, I feel fortunate to know that I've been a part of them, but I do. I feel fortunate to know that I've been a part of great projects that appeal to massive audiences. It gives me a sensation of connection. I'm connecting with human beings that even though I will never ever meet them, I'm connected to them somehow through the stories that impact them, that impact me by being a part of, you know?
但我确实，我感到很幸运能成为那些吸引了海量观众的伟大项目的一部分。这带给我一种连接感。我正在与人类建立联系，尽管我永远、永远不会见到他们，但某种程度上，我通过那些影响了他们、也通过参与其中而影响了我的故事与他们连结在了一起，你知道吗？
And, you know, I've always said this, it's not bad for, you know, a little brown girl from Queens. I just, you know, I feel excited. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Was there any other thing that you ever contemplated doing when you were a little girl? I love animals and children.
而且，你知道的，我一直这么说，对于一个来自皇后区的黑皮肤小女孩来说，这已经很不错了。我只是，你知道的，我感到很兴奋。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。当你是小女孩的时候，有没有想过做点别的什么？我喜欢动物和小孩子。
So there's- Two groups I love to work with. I think I would have gone into some form of psychology for and working with children. There's something about just understanding children and really looking at them for who they are and not overestimating them or underestimating them. That is, it will always be my goal.
所以有——我喜欢共事的两类群体。我想我可能会从事某种心理学方面的工作，跟孩子们一起工作。就是有那么一种感觉，去理解孩子们，真正把他们当作他们自己来看待，既不过高估计他们，也不过低估计他们。那将永远是我的目标。
It's to sort of go, oh my God, where are you? Who are you? What are you? And how can I reach you? It doesn't mean I'm the best mom, but I wake up every day and that's like, that's the only role that I want to pursue every day. How old are your boys?
那就是去感叹，天哪，你在哪里？你是谁？你是什么？我该如何走近你？这并不意味着我是个最好的妈妈，但我每天醒来，这就是我每天想要追求的唯一角色。你的男孩们多大了？
They're going, they're nine, nine and seven. Nine, nine and seven. Okay, nine, nine and seven. So now that you're a parent, is there anything that you recognize as being a very sort of American way of parenting as opposed to how you were raised and what you experienced?
他们快要，九岁，九岁和七岁。九岁，九岁和七岁。好吧，九岁，九岁和七岁。所以现在你成了父母，有没有什么事情，你觉得这是一种非常“美国式”的育儿方式，与你的成长经历和所见所闻截然不同？
Oh God, I love the American way of parenting. When it's, you know, in the sense of this, there's this curiosity to always evolve and figure out better ways of communication with children. I love that. I love that. And this quest to verbally just create freedom where children can communicate their emotions and their feelings
哦天哪，我喜欢美国的育儿方式。当它，你知道的，体现在这种情况下，总是有一种去不断进化、寻找与孩子沟通的更好方式的好奇心。我喜欢这一点。我喜欢这样。以及这种在言语上创造自由的追求，让孩子们能够更早地
early on earlier. I love that about American ways of parenting and the Latino ways of parenting I love because it's all heart. It's very much heart. The child is allowed to be dramatic and excessively dramatic. Like it's just, it's how does that, you know, we talk about death, we normalize death. And we don't sterilize it, it's passion. There's a lot of passion and fire in the way that we raise children, Latinos. But things that I can live without is this, you respect your superiors, you don't question things.
表达他们的情绪和感受。我喜欢美国育儿方式的这一点，我也喜欢拉丁裔的育儿方式，因为那里充满着爱心。非常走心。允许孩子表现得戏剧化，甚至过度戏剧化。就像是，我们怎么看待，你知道的，我们谈论死亡，我们把死亡常规化。我们不会把它变得死板，那里面充满激情。我们在抚养孩子的方式中有很多激情和火花，我们拉丁裔是这样的。但我可以没有的东西是：你必须尊敬长辈，你不能质疑事情。
You just, I love that my kids question everything. What's the Italian way to raise? Oh my God, it's just gelato every day. Yeah, yeah. Gelato every day. Sounds like a train. It's a culture that's very, I mean Latinos and Italians are very similar.
我就是，我喜欢我的孩子们对每件事都提出质疑。意大利人的养育方式是什么样的？哦天哪，就是每天都吃意式冰淇淋。对，对。每天都吃意式冰淇淋。听起来像是一次旅行。这种文化非常，我是说拉丁裔和意大利人非常相似。
They're just affectionate. The fathers are very affectionate with their children and I love that. Do you spend a lot of time over there in Europe with your kids? Do you guys come over there? We do, we do. You do?
他们都很深情。父亲对孩子们非常深情，我喜欢这一点。你在欧洲那边陪孩子们花很多时间吗？你们会去那边吗？我们会的，我们会。会吗？
And Marco, I think it's so cool, Marco's your husband. Marco took your last name. He did. Come on. That's so cool. Wait, walk me through that conversation. That came from him. We get married.
还有马尔科，我觉得这太酷了，马尔科是你的丈夫。马尔科随了你的姓。他确实随了。拜托。太酷了。等等，带我回顾一下当时的那段对话。那是他主动提出来的。我们结婚时。
I had no intentions of changing my name, but we never discussed it. It was just, I just had it there. I'm like, in case the conversation comes up, I'm gonna let him down slowly that I'm going to remain Zoe Saldana, and maybe throughout the years, if we earn it, then maybe I can take a Perigo somewhere.
我根本没打算改姓，但我们从未讨论过这件事。我只是把这件事放在那里。我想，万一谈到这个话题，我要委婉地告诉他我打算继续叫佐伊·萨尔达娜（Zoe Saldana），也许随着时间的推移，如果我们赢得了这个权利，那么也许我可以在某个地方加上佩雷戈（Perigo）这个姓。
And he was immediately, he's like, I'm going to be Marco Perigo Saldaña. And I'm very sure you should probably just do it in our personal lives, but keep your professional name as who you are. Society sometimes doesn't really understand. He goes, I don't give a shit. Like, I'm proud of your name.
而他立刻就说，我要成为马尔科·佩雷戈·萨尔达娜（Marco Perigo Saldaña）。而且我非常确定，你大概应该在我们的个人生活中这么做，但在职业上保留你本来的名字。社会有时并不能真正理解。他说，我才他妈不在乎呢。我是为你这个姓氏感到骄傲。
I love your father's name. What was the impetus for that though, for him, do you think? For him, it was, I mean, I get emotional. My father died when I was nine. And I've never, I mean, I have a wonderful stepdad that's been in our life since I was 13. And he's my dad, you know. But my biological father, that bond,
我爱你的父亲的姓氏。不过，你觉得他这么做的契机是什么？对V他来说，我是说，我有些情绪激动。我父亲在我九岁时去世了。我从来没有，我是说，我有一个出色的继父，自我13岁起就一直陪伴在我们的生命中。他就是我的爸爸，你知道的。但我的亲生父亲，那种纽带，
that connection to your blood was lost, abruptly lost very early on. So it's not something you ever heal from. It's just you learn to manage that pain of loss. Right, right, right. And when we fell in love and we got married, he knows how strong of a presence my father still is in my life, because as Latinos, we live with our dead.
那种与你血脉相连的羁绊，很早就突然地、彻底地消失了。所以这不是一件你能彻底治愈的事情。你只是学会了如何去应对那种失去的痛苦。对，对，对。当我们相爱并结婚时，他知道我父亲在我生命中的存在感有多么强烈，因为作为拉丁裔，我们与逝者共同生活。
We live with them. We actively talk about them as if they're here, you know? Did your family or your mom, like back then, like suggest therapy, like for a young child like yourself to go through such- We did it, yeah. Or did you get through it as a family and was like, no, we don't believe in that. We're going to get through this together. No, it, yeah. Or did you get through it as a family and was like, no, we don't believe in that,
我们与他们同在。我们积极地谈论他们，就好像他们还在这里一样，你知道吗？你的家人或你妈妈，在当时，比如有没有建议去做心理治疗，针对像你这样经历过如此——我们经历过了，对。还是你们作为一家人挺过来了，然后觉得，不，我们不相信那一套。我们要一起度过难关。没有，它，对。还是你们作为一家人挺过来了，然后觉得，不，我们不相信那一套，
we're gonna get through this together? No, no, no, it was a combination of both. Yeah, that's good, very smart. We were still living in the States when he passed away and back in the 80s, public schools in New York were incredible, they were just incredible. So immediately, as soon as we came back from the funeral, they bombarded us with just love and support.
我们要一起度过难关？不，不，不，那是两者的结合。对，那很好，非常聪明。他去世时我们还住在美国，在80年代，纽约的公立学校简直不可思议，它们真的是太棒了。所以我们一从葬礼回来，他们立刻就用爱和支持将我们包围了。
And for my mom as well, they, you know, they, my mom, you know, had places to go to and sort of cope with this and, you know, gain new tools on how to be like this single parent moving forward. And then when we went back to Dominican Republic, then that was when we moved there then to live, then it was very much like, no, we stick together,
对我妈妈也是一样，他们，你知道的，我妈妈，你知道的，有可以去的地方来应对这一切，并且，你知道的，获得了关于如何作为一个单亲母亲继续前行的新工具。然后当我们回到多米尼加共和国时，我们搬到那里去生活，那时候的情况就很像：不，我们要团结在一起，
God will always find his way. So that had his, that had its good things and also bad things, you know, and my mom did feel very isolated at times when it came to just trying to talk to a professional, but the love and support was always abundant in our family, you know? Oh, that's great, that's great.
上帝自有安排。所以这有它好的一面，也有不好的一面，你知道的，我妈妈在试图与专业人士交流时，有时确实会感到非常孤立，但在我们的家庭里，爱和支持总是无比充沛的，你知道吗？哦，那太棒了，那太棒了。
And wait, if you don't mind, how did you meet your husband? I think he, didn't he hit on you on the plane once or something and then you turned him down? On the plane? How did he find you after the? Well, he just, he's very Italian and I, you know, I love the Italian culture, but I'm also like, I'm keeping it at bay.
还有，如果你不介意的话，你是怎么遇到你丈夫的？我记得他，他是不是有一次在飞机上对你搭讪还是怎么的，然后你拒绝了他？在飞机上？后来他是怎么找到你的？嗯，他这个人非常意大利，而我，你知道的，我喜欢意大利文化，但我也同时在想，我得保持警惕。
You know what I mean? It's a very romantic and seductive culture. So he meets you and he's this like pirate looking, probably the most handsomest man I'll ever meet in my life. And I met him on a plane, but we knew each other. We knew of each other through mutual friends. And it was always like, oh, there's that guy. There's that really handsome, hot motherfucking guy
你知道我的意思吗？这是一种非常浪漫且具有诱惑力的文化。所以他遇到了你，他长得像个海盗，可能是我这辈子见过的最英俊的男人。我在飞机上遇到了他，但我们互相认识。我们通过共同的朋友知道彼此。当时的感觉总是：哦，就是那个家伙。就是那个长得超级帅、性感得要命的混蛋，
that I should always stay away from. Because he looks at you, and he just has that suave look and everything, and when he talks to you, he had that little bitchy, you know, they kind of hide their real manly voice, and I'm like, why are you such a high-pitched voice when you talk to me? And I'm a New Yorker, I'm very much like,
我本来应该一直离他远远的。因为他看着你的时候，自带那种温文尔雅的眼神和一切，而当他跟你说话时，他又带着那种有点刻薄的腔调，你知道的，他们会刻意隐藏自己真正的男子汉嗓音，我就想，你跟我说话时为什么声音要装得这么尖？我是个纽约人，我非常直接，
come on, man, talk to me. But I'm a New Yorker, I'm very much like, come on man, talk to me. But he's gentle, my husband is a very gentle man. That's so great. And you teach your kids Spanish and Italian at home? I mean, we don't necessarily teach it, we just are. That's how we slip in and out of all these languages. That's so cool. And it's funny because I grew up as a daughter of immigrants
拜托，老兄，痛快点跟我说话。但我是个纽约人，我非常直接：拜托，老兄，痛快点跟我说话。但他很温柔，我丈夫是一个非常温柔的人。太棒了。你在家里教你的孩子说西班牙语和意大利语吗？我的意思是，我们不一定是刻意去教，我们只是自然而然地使用。我们就是在所有这些语言之间自如切换。太酷了。说来搞笑，因为我是作为移民的女儿长大的，
where you live a double life. You feel like you're like 007, where in your house, you're like, hola, abuela, and you're very Latina. And the moment you step out, you kind of go, adios. We're like, hey, what's up? How you doing? You learn to code switch, right? Because they're so hard on you.
在那种环境下，你过着双重生活。你觉得自己就像007一样，在家里，你会说：hola，abuela（你好，外婆），你表现得非常拉丁。而一旦你走出去，你就会说：adiós。我们就像是：嘿，最近怎么样？过得好吗？你学会了语言切换，对吧？因为他们对你要求太严了。
You don't forget your culture. You don't forget where you come from. And it was very much like that. I appreciate that today. And then I marry an immigrant who's very much about, I'm Italian, Italian forever. We're Italians. We don't know, know, know, know. And so when the boys were little, they spoke only Italian and Spanish.
你不能忘记你的文化。你不能忘记你来自哪里。情况确实很像那样。我今天很感激这一点。然后我嫁给了一个移民，他非常坚持：我是意大利人，永远都是意大利人。我们是意大利人。我们不能这样那样。所以当男孩们小的时候，他们只说意大利语和西班牙语。
But as soon as they start going to school and I start dialoguing with them, I go into what feels very, you know. And they pick up on it. And we became very English oriented in the way that we bond. And then that's when my husband's family, because our folks live here in the States and my parents also live in California,
但一旦他们开始上学，我开始与他们对话，我就会不由自主地切换到那种感觉非常，你知道的。他们也顺理成章地学会了。我们在维系亲密关系时变得非常偏向英语。然后就在那个时候，我丈夫的家人——因为我们的亲戚住在美国，我的父母也住在加州，
they were just like, you need to talk to them. And I had to kind of have an intervention. I'm like, y'all need to chill. Okay? You guys all chose to come here. We're all here. They are American as well as they are this and this. So share, like we're gonna,
他们就说：你们需要跟他们交流。我不得不进行了一次某种程度的干预。我说：你们都冷静一下好吗？好吧？你们所有人都选择来到这里，我们都在这儿。他们既是美国人，也是这样那样的人。所以分享吧，我们会，
I'm gonna allow you guys to share who we are inherently, but they don't force them. Because we're eating in Italian and Spanish. We are dancing and we are communicating in it. That's already enough. It's going to be there. But don't force it to them because then they're going to reject it.
我会允许你们分享我们骨子里的身份，但不要强迫他们。因为我们在吃意大利菜和西班牙菜。我们在跳舞，我们在用那些语言交流。这就已经足够了。它会自然而然存在的。但不要强迫他们，否则他们会抗拒的。
Like I tried to reject it when I was little. And they kind of like, it was a nice intervention because even my husband had to sit him down. I'm like, you need to like, you know, just lay off the gas a little bit. And now they understand it fluently. They'll speak it with their grandparents. But with me, they speak mainly English.
就像我小时候也试图抗拒一样。他们觉得，这次干预其实挺好的，甚至连我丈夫也被我拉着坐下来谈。我说：你得，你知道的，稍微松一松油门。现在他们已经能流利地听懂了。他们会跟祖父母说那些语言。但对我和我来说，他们主要说英语。
I do speak to them in Spanish a lot when we're in public, when I don't want people to know what I'm saying. And then my husband does the same. Yeah, yeah. So wait, I want to get back to career stuff, because I'm obviously a massive fan, that's why you're here. Shoot, I love you.
不过当我们在公众场合、当我不想让别人听懂我在说什么时，我确实经常用西班牙语跟他们说话。我丈夫也是这样。对，对。所以等等，我想回到职业方面的话题，因为我显然是你的超级粉丝，这也是你为什么会来到这里。天哪，我爱你。
Lioness, season two, we'll talk about that in a second. I hear that's incredible. Amelia Perez, we're going to watch tonight. Center Stage, I loved, it was 2000 or so long ago, and I loved that movie. And then after that you did Crossroads with Britney Spears at such a young age when Britney was huge. Were you like, oh my God, I'm in a movie with Britney Spears.
《特别行动：母狮》第二季，我们待会儿再聊这个。我听说那个棒极了。还有《艾米莉·佩雷斯》，我们今晚要看。《中心舞台》，我很喜欢，那是2000年左右的事了，我非常喜欢那部电影。在那之后，你又在那么年轻的时候和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯一起演了《十字路口》，当时布兰妮正当红。你当时是不是觉得，哦天哪，我和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯一起拍电影了。
I mean, what year was that? That was like 2002? We started shooting right after, no, pardon me. We started shooting early 2001. One, okay. It was before 9-11, I remember that. Because you auditioned a lot when you came back from the Dominican Republic and you were still a lot when you came back from the Dominican Republic,
我是说，那是哪一年？大概是2002年吧？我们开拍是在，不对，抱歉。我们是在2001年初开始拍摄的。2001年，好的。那是9·11之前，我还记得这一点。因为你从多米尼加共和国回来后参加了大量试镜，而且你当时还很年轻，
and you were still so young when you're auditioning. Do you have any crazy audition stories? Did you have to do one for the Britney Spears thing? Did you have to read with her? I did, yes, I auditioned. I mean, I auditioned for Amelia Paris, too. So, I mean, it was, but it's more like an interview. Like, you just do a conversation.
当你去试镜的时候还那么年轻。你有什么疯狂的试镜故事吗？你为布兰妮·斯皮尔斯那个项目试镜过吗？你得和她对戏吗？我试镜过，是的。我是说，我也为《艾米莉·佩雷斯》试镜过。所以，我是说，那过程，但它更像是一场面试。就像，你们只是进行了一次对话。
I auditioned a lot. I remember I auditioned for a film that you were doing, Jason. Uh-oh. Years ago. I had nothing to do with it. No, no, it's okay. What was the one that you did about the funeral? Oh, this is where I leave you?
我试镜过很多次。我记得我为你正在制作的一部电影试镜过，杰森。噢哦。多年前。那跟我没关系。不，不，没关系。你拍的那部关于葬礼的是哪一部？哦，是《留下的日子》（This Is Where I Leave You）吗？
Yes, yes. But I bombed. I was so bad. I was so bad at that audition. Wasn't it terrible, right? You can practice as much as you want at home, I was so bad, I was so bad at that audition. Um. I was so bad at that audition. I was so bad at that audition. Isn't it terrible, right? You can practice as much as you want at home and then you get in that room and the nerves take over
对，对。但我演砸了。我演得太差了。我在那场试镜里表现得太糟糕了。是不是超级糟糕，对吧？你在家里可以练习多少次都行，但我当时太差劲了，我在那场试镜里太差劲了。呃。我在那场试镜里表现得太糟糕了。我在那场试镜里表现得太糟糕了。是不是超级糟糕，对吧？你在家里可以练习多少次都行，但一旦你走进那个房间，紧张感就会占据上风，
and your inability to do what you planned on is just, ugh, it's so frustrating. It's awful, I hated that process. I really did because it really fed into my anxiety in a way that wasn't healthy. Competition and fighting to prove who you are is so hard. I do remember that if it wasn't for just warm people, amazing casting directors,
而你无法发挥出你原本计划的那种水平，啊，这太令人沮丧了。太糟糕了，我讨厌那个过程。我真的讨厌，因为它确实以一种不健康的方式加剧了我的焦虑。竞争和为了证明自己是谁而苦苦挣扎是如此艰难。我确实记得，如果不是因为那些热情的人、了不起的选角导演，
like New York has amazing casting directors that were just human beings. They were nice and gentle. And I loved walking in and feeling like they were rooting for me. Whenever I would put myself on tape, because remember, it was like, you have to put yourself on tape when you live in New York.
就像纽约拥有那些真正有人情味的了不起的选角导演。他们人很好，也很温柔。我很喜欢走进去，并且能感觉到他们在为我加油。每当我把试带寄过去的时候——因为记住，当时的情况是，如果你住在纽约，你必须得把试带寄过去。
That's what you got to do. And if it wasn't for the fact that people were nice, I would have never booked parts. It's when people are super cold and they were so despondent and I would tank all of those auditions. It doesn't help. And then you did, by the way, I mean, we could spend two hours,
那就是你必须要做的事。如果不是因为大家都很友善，我绝不可能接到角色。每当遇到那些超级冷漠、沮丧气馁的人时，我所有的试镜都会彻底泡汤。那根本无济于事。然后你做到了，顺便说一句，我是说，我们可以花上两个小时，
Pirates of the Caribbean, The Terminal with Tim Hanks, Star Trek, Marvel with Guardians of the Galaxy, but I have to say, my husband Scotty, he's a massive, massive, massive Star Trek fan. I'm more of a Star Wars, but because of your films. This is the only thing they fight about. Yeah, but because of your films and JJ and everybody involved,
《加勒比海盗》、《幸福终点站》（与汤姆·汉克斯合作）、《星际迷航》、《银河护卫队》这样的漫威电影，但我必须得说，我丈夫斯科蒂（Scotty），他是一个超级、超级、超级坚定的《星际迷航》粉丝。我更喜欢《星球大战》，但因为你们的电影。这是他们唯一会争吵的事情。对，但因为你们的电影以及J·J和所有参与的人，
I was blown away by you and those films. They're so well made. Thank you. And it's completely gripping and suck you in and in the best way. There's gonna be another one due soon, right? Another Star Trek movie? They're talking about it and it would be nice.
我被你和那些电影深深地震撼了。它们制作得太精良了。谢谢。而且完全扣人心弦，用最好的方式把你吸引进去。很快又会有一部上映对吧？另一部《星际迷航》电影？他们正在讨论这事，如果有的话那就太好了。
It would be nice for us to come back and sort of do a proper send off to the next generation. Look, I don't, honestly, I wish I had like a formula. I feel like the only thing that I kept doing was saying yes. Yeah, well that's interesting. You know, was just like if I was shooting Avatar and all of a sudden my agents at the time were calling me
我们能回归并为下一代人做一个郑重的告别，那就太好了。听着，我真的，我希望我有什么秘诀。我觉得我一直在做的事情就是说“好”。对，那很有意思。你知道的，就像我当时正在拍《阿凡达》，突然我当时的经纪人打电话给我，
and it's like, well JJ Abrams really wants to meet you for Uhura, he's going to shoot this next Star Trek. I was like, who what? I wasn't a Star Trek fan, my mom was. And I was like, well okay. I know, and I'm like, but I'm working. And he's like, well, I think he's going to come to set. I think, I'm like, oh okay,
说J·J·艾布拉姆斯真的很想见你，想让你演乌乎拉（Uhura），他要拍下一部《星际迷航》。我当时想，什么谁？我不是《星际迷航》的粉丝，我妈妈是。然后我想，好吧。我懂，而且我在想，但我正在工作呢。他说，嗯，我觉得他要来片场。我觉得，我说，哦好吧，
because I would go to the set of Avatar, and every day he's like, oh, there's Robert Zemeckis, there's Steven Spielberg, there's George Lucas, there's, you know, they were always there. And Jim was giving him the whole walkthrough, so it was very normal for us to see these amazing filmmakers. And Jim walks to set one day, goes,
因为我会去《阿凡达》的片场，他每天都在那儿，哦，那是罗伯特·泽米吉斯，那是史蒂芬·斯皮尔斯，那是乔治·卢卡斯，那是，你知道的，他们总是在那儿。吉姆在带他们做整体参观，所以对我们来说，看到这些了不起的电影人是非常平常的事。有一天吉姆走到片场，说道：
I have a surprise for you, and I think you're going to owe me for this one. And I was like, what is he talking about? And JJ was there. And JJ was like, hi Zoe, and Jim lets him touch the camera, and did the whole tour, and then JJ's like, well, are you,
我有个惊喜给你，我觉得你这次得好好谢谢我。我当时想，他在说什么呢？然后J·J就在那儿。J·J说，嗨，佐伊，吉姆让他摸了摸摄像机，还做了一整套参观，然后J·J就说，嗯，你，
I definitely want to meet you for Ahura, for Star Trek. And then JJ left and Jim just comes over and goes, you're welcome. And I'm like, for what? I wasn't really tapping into it. And then I get the call, like, can you please play Ahura? I was like, absolutely, are you kidding me? Let me think about it, yeah.
我绝对想见你谈谈乌乎拉这个角色，为了《星际迷航》。然后J·J走了，吉姆走过来对我说：不客气。我说：谢什么？我当时根本没反应过来。然后我接到了电话，问：你能不能演乌乎拉？我说：当然可以，你在开玩笑吗？让我想想，好啊。
Yes, and then after that, it was Yes, and then after that it was just, and then after that James Gunn comes over, and years later goes, can you play Gamora? I'm like, yeah, of course. And I said yes because I wanted to experience prosthetics. Yeah. Makeup, like waking up at 3 o'clock in the morning and going through the whole nutty professor transformation.
好的，然后在那之后，就是，好啊，然后在那之后詹姆斯·古恩走了过来，几年后说：你能演卡魔拉（Gamora）吗？我说：行，当然可以。我答应是因为我想体验一下特效化妆。对。化妆，比如早上3点钟醒来，经历那种疯狂教授式的蜕变。
I was like, I want to do that. And then a month in I was like, I hate this. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Two, three hours sitting in the chair, not doing anything. Eating through a straw, yeah. Yeah, what about the series, the Star Trek series where those people have to be in that every single day for nine, 10 months a year.
我当时想：我想试试这个。结果一个月后我想：我恨死这个了。对，对，对。在椅子上坐两三个小时，什么也做不了。用吸管吃东西，对。对，那那些电视剧里的演员怎么办，那些人一年里有九到十个月每天都得顶着那个妆。
I wouldn't be able to do it. It never doesn't make me laugh though. The idea of an actor in a Klingon, all the Klingon makeup, walking through craft service. That always will make me laugh. Just like getting fried chicken and like, you know. Eating everything, put it in a blender right through a straw. Yeah.
我肯定做不到。不过这总能逗笑我。一个穿着克林贡人（Klingon）服装、化着所有克林贡妆容的演员走过剧组餐饮区的画面。那总是能把我逗笑。就像去拿炸鸡，然后，你知道的。吃所有东西，放进搅拌机里用吸管吸着喝。对。
And like collar napkin always to not get makeup on their outfits, yeah. Wait, so all of the travels and all of the places you've worked in the world, I want to ask where you would choose to live if you had to pick a place, either fictional or non-fictional? Paris.
还有像餐巾纸一样的衣领，为了不让化妆弄脏他们的衣服，对。等等，那么你所有的旅行以及你在世界各地工作过的地方，我想问问，如果必须选一个地方生活，无论是虚构的还是现实的，你会选哪里？巴黎。
Oh really? Yes. You love Paris. I love Paris. Why? I love art. I love the fact that people are always outside. I love to walk as a New Yorker. I just I love to walk down streets of ancient ancient history. And I love eating and drinking
哦真的吗？对。你爱巴黎。我爱巴黎。为什么？我热爱艺术。我喜欢人们总是在室外活动这一点。作为纽约人，我喜欢走路。我就是喜欢漫步在古老、古老历史的街道上。而且我喜欢吃东西、喝
wine. So it's just it's really romantic. And there's something really nice about Paris, but also like when you go to Italy, because my second favorite place Italy and then it's the Caribbean. I'm from the Caribbean. I love the beach, I love the water. But there's just something very free about Europe that in the summers, you see people in love, living in love in public. The universal language. And you'll see these younger couples,
葡萄酒。所以这真的很浪漫。巴黎有一种非常美妙的特质，但还有当你去意大利的时候，因为我的第二大最爱是意大利，然后是加勒比海。我来自加勒比海。我喜欢海滩，我喜欢水。但欧洲有一种非常自由的感觉，在夏天，你会看到相爱的人们在公共场合公开地生活在爱中。那是通用的语言。你会看到这些年轻的情侣，
like on the Vespa, making out while you're like, you know, taking your kid for a walk. But then the same couple, you come back and they're in the same Vespa and she's slapping the crap out of him. Stranzo! No, but like, cos' he did that. And then all of a sudden he grabs her and shakes her and he kisses her. And you're like, fuck, that's so romantic and dramatic.
比如在Vespa（韦士帕踏板摩托车）上热吻，而你正带着孩子散步。但转过头来，同一对情侣，当你折返回来时，他们还在同一辆Vespa上，而她正在狠狠地抽他耳光。Stronzo!（混蛋！）不，但就像是因为他做了什么。然后突然之间他抓住她、摇晃她，接着又亲吻她。你会觉得：操，这太浪漫、太戏剧化了。
And you know what I'm talking about. Yeah, Jason and I are going to do that later tonight. Oh yeah, oh yeah. Yeah. Which one do you want to be? You want to be shaken or the shaker? Both, both shakers. Well, listen, I could talk to you for 19 hours.
你知道我在说什么。对，杰森和我今晚待会儿就要这么干。哦对，哦对。对。你想当哪个角色？你想当被摇晃的还是去摇晃人的？两个都当，两个都当摇晃者。好吧，听着，我可以跟你聊19个小时。
We've taken up way too much of your time. Me too, you guys. Thank you for this conversation. I've enjoyed it. Thank you so much. I can't wait to see the movie and Lion Me too, you guys. Thank you for this conversation. I've enjoyed it. Thank you so much. I can't wait to see the movie and Lioness. We didn't even talk about Lioness, but Nicole, you and Nicole Kidman, love the show. I love her.
我们已经占用了你太多时间。我也是，你们俩也是。谢谢你们的这次对话。我很享受。非常感谢。我等不及要看这部电影和《母狮》了。我也是，你们俩。谢谢你们的这次对话。我很享受。非常感谢。我等不及要看这部电影和《母狮》了。我们甚至还没聊到《母狮》，但妮可，你和妮可·基德曼，我太爱这部剧了。我爱她。
Of course you're getting a second season. So I can't wait. But thank you for being your gigantic fan. Thank you guys. Very, very nice to see you. Thank you for this conversation. Anytime. I'll come back.
当然你们会有第二季的。所以我迫不及待了。但谢谢你，作为一个超级巨大的粉丝。谢谢你们。非常、非常高兴见到你们。谢谢你们的这次对话。随时奉陪。我会回来的。
Please do. Thank you so much. Love you. All right, enjoy the rest of your day. Bye. You too. Bye, sweetie. Oh, Shawnee. Yeah, I love her.
一定要来。非常感谢。爱你们。好啦，享受你们剩下的一天吧。再见。你也是。再见，亲爱的。哦，肖妮。对，我爱她。
I want to talk to her forever. And she's like, you know, how many people can say, I know we already said in the show. The biggest. I mean, the three, there's no other actor that was in the top three movies of all time. No. There's no other actor.
我想永远跟她聊天。她就像是，你知道的，有多少人能说——我知道我们刚才在节目里已经说过了。最厉害的。我是说，前三名，没有其他演员曾位列影史票房前三。没有。没有其他演员了。
Isn't that wild? There's very few, yeah, it's very wild. I mean. A stunning accomplishment. What I was thinking about during it is that she's been in all those big, right? And then on the other end, I was in Brother Solomon. And if you think about the gap between those.
不是很疯狂吗？确实很少，对，非常疯狂。我是说。一个惊人的成就。我当时在想的是，她演过所有那些大片，对吧？然后另一方面，我演过《所罗门兄弟》（The Brothers Solomon）。如果你想想这中间的差距。
There's a lot of daylight in between. There's a lot of daylight. It's all daylight, let's be honest. But I didn't even get to the terminal. Remember she was in the terminal with Tom Hanks? Terminal, yes! She was great. I really like her a lot and I want to hang out with her.
中间有很多空白期。有很多空白期。老实说，全都是空白期。但我甚至还没提到《幸福终点站》。还记得她跟汤姆·汉克斯一起演过《幸福终点站》吗？《幸福终点站》，对！她演得真棒。我真的很喜欢她，我想和她一起混。
Sure, and to your point, Sean, I mean it's such an accomplishment, you know? To my point. Well, welkommen. Maybe they mean welkommen. Welkommen. welkommen. Ah, velkomen. Maybe they mean welkommen. Welkommen. Welkommen. By the way, if they were German,
当然，而且正如你所说，肖恩，这真是一个巨大的成就，你知道吗？正如我所说。好吧，欢迎（welkommen）。也许他们说的是德语的“欢迎”（welkommen）。欢迎。欢迎。啊，欢迎（velkommen）。也许他们说的是“欢迎”。欢迎。欢迎。顺便说一句，如果他们是德国人，
then I'm gonna take it, obviously. They're close to the candles. Okay, you know what I mean? Anyway, she's wonderful. She's amazing, she's amazing. She's one of a kind. She is one of a kind. She's so rare, I would dare to say.
那我当然就接受了。他们离蜡烛很近。好吧，你知道我的意思吗？不管怎样，她太棒了。她太惊艳了，太惊艳了。她是独一无二的。她真的是独一无二。她极其罕见，我敢这么说。
Uh-oh, do it. Be brave. Don't. You can feel it. This is where it's embarrassing, where you can feel it. Is that she's so, you know, people who have been in so many huge films like that, they're not every day. In fact, they're pretty hard to come by. Boring.
噢哦，说吧。勇敢点。别。你能感觉得到。这就是尴尬的地方，你能感觉得到。那就是她太，你知道的，那些演过那么多超级大片的演员，并不是每天都能遇到的。事实上，他们相当难得。无聊。
Boring. Boring. Boring. Boring. Boring. Boring. to dot edu smart list is 100 percent organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant-Terry. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无聊。无聊。无聊。无聊。无聊。无聊。SmartLess 播客节目由罗伯特·阿姆吉夫（Rob Armgerve）、本尼特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）和迈克尔·格兰特-特里（Michael Grant-Terry）100% 有机手工精制而成。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。